اسميهم مستوطنين ارهابيين لانهم نشروا
الرعب هنا في هذه الضواحي والاحياء من
خلال اطلاق النار على الفلسطينيين واصابه
12 شخصا وقتل عمر جباره
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم بعد ايام من التوتر في
فلسطين وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
يطالب بالقيام بعمليه عسكريه واسعه في
الضفه ويدعو المستوطنين للتمسك بالبؤر
الاستيطانيه ممثل الاتحاد الاوروبي يصف في
تصريح للجزيره هجوم المستوطنين على
الفلسطينيين بانه عمل ارهابي وبرلين تنسحب
من بيان مؤيد لاسرائيل يدين عمل لجنه
تحقيق امميه بسبب توسع حكومه نتنياهو
الاستيطاني القوات الاوكرانيه تؤكد تقدمها
جنوبا وايقافها هجوم الروسيا في الشرق
ومؤسس مجموعه باجنر يقول ان القوات
الروسيه تتراجع امام هجومي اوكرانيا
المضاد موسكو تحضير كييف مما وصفتها
بحوادث خطيره ومحتمله في محطه
تقول للجزيره ان لدى اوكرانيا ما تحتاجه
حاليا كي تحق مكاسب في الميدان ماساه
جديده من مسلسل الهجره غير النظاميه مسؤول
تونسي يقول ان ما لا يقل عن 12 مهاجرا
افريقيا فقدوا وتوفي ثلاثه اخرين بعد غرق
ثلاثه قوارب قباله سواحل تونس اثناء
محاولتهم عبور البحر المتوسط الى ايطاليا
يوتيوب تعلن عن خدمه اللوت التي تستخدم
تقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي لدبلجه مقاطع
الفيديو الى عده لغات اخرى حيث ستنسخ
الاداه ما يقال في الفيديو الى نص يمكن
للمستخدم مراجعته وتحريره ثم تعمل على
ترجمته وانتاج الدبلجه فيها الى اللقاء